c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche ça qu'est ce que vous en
pensez pas ce que vous avez connu
l'avant télé réalité il est maintenant
la téléréalité kate abbaoui parce que je
suis vieux je sais pas j'ai commencé
chez ravet y avait trois chaînes de
télévision le haut une qui finissait à
20 heures franchement c'était terminé
non je déteste ça les ch'tis à machins
là à la campagne à la montagne
je sais qui je sais qu'il n'est pas cinq
heures du matin parce que je sais que on
est en fin de journée mais très très
franchement voulez que je vous dise ça
me casse les couilles vous ça vous est
déjà arrivé je me suis dit non avec un
garçon
[Rires]
j'ai rarement j'ai rarement et moi je
bois pas d'alcool ouais donc quand je
s'arrête arrivait de boire de l'alcool
et quand je bois la cote je suis sous
très vite et en coma éthylique très très
vite et donc je me suis réveillé dans
une chambre d'hôtel où on m'avait emmené
parce que je pouvais ni conduire ni
marcher ni parler machin on m'a mis dans
le lit et quand je me réveille le matin
il y avait un type à côté de moi qui
était là pour me surveiller au kg déjà
les mâles qui vous happe les chatons
grèce
attention c'est nier et surtout place
alors michel allé j'ai regardé
discrètement ce qui n'est pas sûr
discrètement regarder ce qu'il ya dans
cette cabine
vous allez voir c'est la cabine à bloc
on peut y mettre n'importe quoi michel
c'est bon vous avez vu ce qu'ils avaient
oui regardez également ce qu'il ya
quartier la tête de michel j'adore alors
mes chers
c'est le monsieur oui qui présente top
chef et il est habillé en que je me
décarcasse du croc monsieur ducrocq est
en train de me dire donc pour vous il ya
le viet qui fait dans le côté top chef
qui ont du croquis et déguisés en
ducrocq oui mais se coiffe grâce assène
failed
comme ça ça te regarde pas moi c'est
vous dire derrière là je vous jure ya
bernard minet et hervé mathoux qui
caresse sur le château bernard minet
après ma semaine sur le crâne car les
sages satori software assure j'ai
compris vous ne le croyez que lui bien
sûr c'est l'animateur de l'émission il
dirige sous les fêtes où vous êtes tous
âges où nous devons aller à l'école et
le car et c'est aussi un débat riche et
vous dit michel oui alors c'est sûr que
c'est michel algues sont égales vous le
chaton wheeler michel à 200 pour go ça
fait du bien quand même de temps en
temps il d'être cru même si on vous
trompez vous croit parce qu'on a quelque
chose de fabuleux à des beats et la
riche élite à l'heure c'est pas pourquoi
ils ont mis une photo où elle le
stéphane rotenberg comme ça subliminal
et c'est bien stéphane rotenberg
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]